[Music]
the reason i win
often
is because i'm not worried about the
person in the middle
got it yeah i didn't change for them
they changed for me
why
because i focused on you
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
i'm super excited to be here obviously
you know it's funny
this is so
literal to my world and
it's fun you know because i
yesterday i was in boston and i spoke to
600
jewelry
store owners and it felt really warm to
me because they're merchants they own a
single store and they sell stuff
and
that obviously is very much where i come
from and then i get to get behind it
to have this event where
so many of the people in this room the
far majority are doing what i'm
currently doing
and yesterday was a lot of fun to
reminisce and challenge myself to think
about what did i do when i had no money
which is really basically the framework
of the talk which is you know a lot of
people in this room that are familiar
with my work i talk about a lot of
progressive things a lot of things but
the reality is
i always remember when i kept trying to
change the narrative in the late in
2014-1516 which is i didn't build wine
library through just social media i did
direct mail
it was search it was email marketing and
i took it way back because i knew that a
lot of people in the room had no
marketing budget and it made me remember
something that is super fun for me which
is literally week one
out of college no marketing budget i
printed a bunch of 20 off by the case of
wine things on a picture i made in some
sort of version of old school photo not
even photoshop yet i mean i was so
computer
illiterate i couldn't even like know
what i was doing and i remember it had a
crab
literally a crab like there was a
default picture of a crab
in a beach and i like was like that's
fine and i put that there and and then
made dotted lines and it said 20 off on
a case of wine non-sale items i printed
a hundred of them came to the store the
next day parked my car ran and opened
the store told one of the kids to keep
an eye on the shop and drove to the
short hills mall
and literally
put those flyers on windshields for an
hour and a half
what's fun about that for me here now is
day one vayner
was super funny
you know and
the reality is i knew nothing about the
advertising industry
uh and i had to learn it and i had to
build and so it's fun for me to be
challenged to remember
what i did
knowing there's a wide range of people
here who are one woman shop to people
that are trying to go from seven to
eight figures very honestly
i wanna really move this into a very
aggressive q a session because i think
you know just based on how many people
hit me up on linkedin and on twitter
over the last 24 hours about this
you know the far majority of this room
at least has some level of context of
what i'm going to talk about or what i
believe and i don't think that brings
you the most value i think what brings
you the most value is probably
ironically and it's fun to see maribel
here who i've worked very closely with
for quite a long time like i'm extremely
proud of my operational capability for
all those incredible things that i heard
you know in the intro just now which are
super fancy and really surreal for me to
think about what i promise every one of
you when i think about business that i'm
most proud of is
21 years ago
i walked into my dad's store and he
decided because he was passionate about
it to renovate the house this is like
family business [ __ ]
and i was in charge now i'd been in the
business since i was 14 every weekend
every summer vacation my dad knew that i
wasn't a schlemiel and i was capable and
even the last two years of college i was
coming home almost every weekend putting
in work
but i walked in
and from that day
to this second
i have not raised capital
i've had a payroll to make
what blows my mind
this is not true with vayner because of
the scale but i didn't even have a
credit line
for wine library and our invoices were
due on 30 days or the distributor would
put you on cod cash on delivery which
would stop you from being able to buy
from any of the distributors the
discipline
that i was raised in
to you know
pay with what you had
right and so i've scrapped
i'm most proud
that for 21 straight years i've had to
make payroll and i have
operations
building an actual business so a lot of
fancy other things have come along the
way
but the connection point i feel for this
room is quite high i have a lot of
thoughts about offense and defense which
is playing out in all of your minds
and so i'd like to bring as much value
as possible so there's two mics that are
lined up so i think it's a good idea to
line up um
good
um
and and and i think
and i think just to create a little more
framework for the q a i know you want to
come out and frame the q a i just love
having you here that was such a good
intro oh really thank you it's really
good well huh you know you know can i
say one thing yeah so you said you said
this you know there was a disclaimer
where somebody was like hey you got to
go out here and tell people that gary
likes to say the f word a lot but then i
was like man you know swearing is a
intelligence thing it's a marxist
intelligence so i was like you but you
bet your butt we are right you know i
appreciate dumb things and listen
ryan ryan told me backstage watched my
mouth so i've thrown one [ __ ] out and
i've kept it fairly clean i'm pretty
pumped but i know somebody's going to
ask a [ __ ] stupid question
and i'm joking because there is no
stupid question on a very serious note
and what i want to set the tone on and
this is where i want to inspire a couple
of you that are still sitting because
they're either more introverted or lazy
or who the hell knows why you didn't get
up
i i
am really passionate about
operations and how to build an actual
business and it's very hard to produce
content for that
that can bring enough value and that's
why i don't go there i found my listen i
think a lot of you have a sense of me
there was a very long time where i went
nowhere close to anything motivational
because i have
0.0 interest in being a motivational
speaker
even though i know many many people view
me that way i'm motivated
i'm optimistic
i'm deeply grateful and happy
and i genuinely do believe that
perspective really really matters
because if you think you've lost before
you've started you actually already lost
and that's real because that happens to
me in things so
i have that in me but i promise you
please feel free to go very detailed
i i don't have a co
i have a thousand people i don't have a
co because i'm operating it
i'm making tangible operational
decisions in the back room right now
i've just been very very thoughtful of
how to create content at scale and post
produced it contextual to the platforms
that matter
but that doesn't take away from the fact
that i'm spending 11 to 14 hours a day
being the ceo and ceo of a thousand
person global agency so i've i have some
thoughts started from scratch so i
i can remember and i understand and i
know
what has worked for me and others that
look like me and what has kept a lot of
people at the 700 000 a year in revenue
business so i really think i can help so
please fire away and i'm really i'm
honestly grateful to be here and i
appreciate it thank you
hey thank you
my name is is this on my name is robin
wilson and i sat there all day long
because i knew that this 55 year old
woman would only have a chance of
getting here if i was closest to the mic
and in the front row so strategy pays
hacking always works
love it so i have um a specific question
so i only do social media marketing at
our agency we only do social and email
but social mainly on that forefront but
we serve a very particular
vertical we serve automotive okay so
we're a women-owned business that do
social media marketing
they're leaders 55 years old like any of
that gives a [ __ ] about anything right
and we um not only just serve the
automotive industry but we really kind
of niche with
subprime uh
dealerships that's kind of where our
forte is is that non-intender market
and so my question has been because
people ask me all the time do you guys
do digital also which means you know
search and we don't because my brain is
only so big yeah and so i don't know
whether i need to partner with somebody
or just continue to let them find their
outsourcing for that
because
digital isn't is a right i understand
and do you do paid and creative or just
paid or just creative paid and creative
understood so
i think the answer is extremely personal
i think
you and everybody else here is not
unaware that when you don't provide a
service it creates a vulnerability that
can lead to you losing your service
right not super complicated we've all
been there um i think it comes down to
and this is actually what a wait thank
you rob this is a great way to start
i literally backstage just made a video
and
for the people that follow me the most
i'm in such post-production film my life
mode that the days of five or six years
ago when i go straight to camera with a
thought video is rare original
programming just for the video is rare
for me these days but i'm so compelled
right now around this thought that
people are not self-aware of what makes
them happy when they run a business and
everybody just thinks about growth
without realizing the next employee or
the next hundred dollars is the
beginning of the process of you not
liking your business anymore
and that's your answer your answer is
predicated on you know it's a
vulnerability
in one way it's also a strength in
another way
you just have to ask yourself are you
happy with the level of business that
you're at
and do if you're not
are you in a place where you think you
can get more
deep narrow
or do you think you need to go wide
right part partnering is no
correct right all partnerships are
vulnerable from the get
it's inconceivable that another business
or human has the same exact interests as
you do and something's going to happen
eventually
and i again this is what makes this fun
the heads are nodding because you lived
it you already thought about the [ __ ]
you did that didn't work and this right
so
that's why we never partnered with
anybody as a matter of fact i never took
a single meeting to partner with anybody
because i knew i was going to do
everything because i'm building it for
myself and i had no interest claiming
that they're the one that told me to do
video you know i didn't want to make
myself vulnerable to somebody claiming
that in a meeting where they were trying
to get me to partner with them that when
i then did what they did i was a dick
so i wouldn't even take the meetings
because i didn't want the reputational
vulnerability because i knew there was
never going to be a scenario where i was
going to partner with anybody i was
going to do everything
perfect answer thank you you know it's a
self-awareness answer
let me say one other thing because i
know this will bring more value to
everybody i'm also a very big fan
when you want to do something else
to not do yesterday's
thing to do tomorrow's
i would much rather a lot of people here
who are on social only
not go and do search and banner and
programmatic but start the process of
affording the ability to do voice in
four years nice because their business
will grow much more
love it thank
but the reason i say voice is i think
voice is dangerously close whereas if
you come up to me and say gary that's
exactly like the next guy was like gary
that's exactly right i'm going to be
doing blockchain advertising to
guarantee you know consumption i'm like
that's further along than you think or
i'm building a vr shop not one person
you know goes home and goes and does vr
which means we're far away
my strength is timing not just seeing it
right
like i'm not talking about tick tock a
whole bunch now because i just [ __ ]
discovered it i was one of the first
users of musically i'm talking about it
now because it's on the cusp of getting
older and that's why i talked about
snapchat even though i invested four
years earlier i wait to things hit a
different level of scale that
accompanies more consumers
timing
and i build the reason vayner got so big
was i invested in the things that i
thought would be soon
and i stayed alive with my salesmanship
to get there
thank you
hi gary how are you i'm great man how
you doing very good what's your name my
name is eric yang
i'm from paris very nice and actually
built a online conference agency
and we actually operated in los angeles
and i've actually been following you
advice which is creating content and
document the entire journey and process
of our work
and actually has been working really
really well for us so figure
what's been interesting is the type of
people that follow us now are mostly
like entrepreneurs that are asian on the
30 which makes sense exactly who i am
and i actually moved to asia to be
closer with that demographic interesting
and my question to you is besides
podcasting what advice would you give
entrepreneurs in asia to build a
personal brand well i think podcasting
is going to have a huge growth in that
area i also think that
you know kols are disproportionately
advanced in asia especially mainland
china and other places so
you know the ability to tap into the
influencer ecosystem in that world is
quite advanced i also think that there's
enormous arbitrage on
all the social networks out in southeast
so we opened up singapore right because
we think the media costs on instagram
and facebook and all and the platforms
that play even line when we go full time
to japan and south korea are even more
underpriced than they are in america our
global expansion has been completely
predicated on the underpriced nature of
the media that we most believe in so the
answer is it doesn't change
my my answer is always the same what are
humans doing
and then bring them the most value in
that channel
i mean again people i know a lot of you
are following at home like the fact that
crushing it only came out like 18 months
ago as a book and spoke nothing of
linkedin and linkedin is the top thing
i'm talking about is wild
it just here's why it's wild it's not a
new thing
it just became underpriced there's a
very dark horse chance that i'm going to
talk a lot about print and direct mail
radio and television one day because the
market so collapses that the price
becomes actually a deal
i i want to buy outdoor billboards when
they're remnant and i can buy them for
two months for 2 000 instead of 34 000.
i'm unemotional
i can't wait to be at a conference like
this in seven years and completely [ __ ]
on social media
because you have to understand you got i
wasn't making content and you weren't
following along when i built my entire
companies on google guys i ran ads on
google the day came out
i bought google adwords for five cents a
click the day it came out for wine terms
that was one of the biggest reasons why
library grew
i did email marketing in 1997. heavy
it was my religion
i had 90 [ __ ] percent open rates
like it was unheard of but it was new
the same rate right now i'm getting a
million
i'm getting hundreds and if not
thousands of emails a day or dms from
people that are thanking me for telling
them to go on tick-tock
it's just arbitrage
but people dig in on the thing they know
and aren't willing to kill the thing
that got him there
that's what's happening in this room
you're not willing to kill the thing
that got you to the dance
when it no longer is the thing
and so you start justifying and you
start [ __ ] on the new thing which
gets you deeper in the hole then you
feel even further behind
that's the game
that's the game
thank you you got it um
i have a
in [ __ ] just to take a shot at this
i am about to launch a podcast you have
six guests lined up already will you be
open to be my seven guest for 15 minutes
two minutes 15.
no what what what about two just two
minutes one question you made a critical
mistake and i'll explain it
if you had booked four guests
i would have definitely done it oh six
people are lined up already they're
pre-recorded i get it but if i could
have been the fifth guest i would be in
but now i'm gonna wait to be the 100th
guest
so when i have 100 when you get 99 in
the bag you send me this clip and i'll
do it done thank you
gary it is always good to see you always
good to see you speaking um
i want to thank you again
i always do i send you emails regularly
to thank you thank you
um
no i i i i something that's freedom i
know
i and i appreciate you you answered one
at 6 30 in the morning on a saturday and
i love you for that um
following your advice
has helped me as you know
grow my company in two and a half years
from zero to
say it a multi-million dollar business
you didn't fully say it huh
go ahead go ahead
go ahead and
i gotta tell you i you know i'm not
nervous speaking to gary i'm just so
moved because
this guy is so real and so genuine and
actually cares like really [ __ ] cares
because because it because it doesn't
come out of mine
the second you understand how much
abundance is in the world
you will change your behavior
absolutely i'm giving away all my best
advice for free at scale
i mean do you know how many people here
have made money by literally parroting
it directly
and i like that that's what i want you
to do
of course i could have all those
customers i'm just not going to get
around to it
do you know how nice this is to hear
admiration
trumps finances every day of the week
good so
at dinner two years ago you asked me a
question
and the question was are you building
this company to buy to to build it and
hold it
or to build it and sell it i remember
and now i want to get it to the next
level to get it to 100 150 million okay
for an exit okay
trying to figure out what our next move
is
i need more context to understand i
think building all these companies here
is actually to build a 100 million
dollar agency you have to be in the hr
business sure
like just so everybody you
you want to get to the punch line i'm
the i'm i spend all my time at hr
that's the answer
we sell people yeah
and i don't understand how you don't
underst you know how we make fun of
rachel probably covered it in some way
but i'm not sure if she went there when
we scrutinize in the dc community
companies that are very good at cac but
suck at ltv they lose
you can acquire companies customers all
day long but if you need to hold onto
them for four months to make it pay off
and they drop off after two and a half
months you're out of business and then
when the price of instagram and facebook
ads go out and your cac is going up
you're really in deep [ __ ]
yet we don't talk about ltv remember how
many years you've been at vayner
i mean these are real when i got into
the business people people
this is super funny because now i'm
thinking i forgot lots of people came to
give me advice
and i you know
i i'm a nice guy so i was cordial but in
my brain i'm like
[ __ ]
my business is gonna be bigger than
yours in 36 months and i don't even know
what i'm doing yet
so your advice is cool but like
everyone's like your people are going to
stay for 18 to 24 months
i'm like no no your people are going to
stay for 18 to 24 months my people are
going to stay for 5 10 and 15 years
because i actually give a [ __ ] about
them
the only way you can build a 100 million
business
is the reason new york jets are in big
trouble right now is their offensive
line has no cohesion because they don't
ever play together at any level
agencies are like offensive lines they
need cohesion
you know how fast you can go
when everybody feels safe
and knows what everybody else is good at
yet people are fearful that they're
gonna lose you know i remember one of
things i established early on if we lose
an account nobody gets fired
because i remember knowing that i had to
establish that
[ __ ] like that
all the stuff that nobody's talking
about
people like people are always it's very
fascinating to me i'm enigma i do
unusual things i talk about my usual
things but everybody wants to focus on
the other stuff because the stuff i do
is hard
people
and i just one final follow-up don't
listen to what he says execute on what
he does watch what he does and do it
i've built my company doing
following his advice and doing exactly
what he roadmaps and he gives away his
best [ __ ]
i directly owe you like there's not
enough wine library wine text
empathy like i subscribe to all of them
i know you know that too i do that
because there's not enough thank yous
that i can give you for the value you're
giving me trying to guilt every [ __ ]
person on earth great job
thank you thanks jerry
hey gary my name is trevor unlike the
gentleman before you i am pretty nervous
so i got a stress ball
give it back but the reason why i wanted
to come up here to say thank you um i
found your content a couple years ago
from the monday morning rant video that
you run all the time yes and the 400
trillion to one kind of really got me
because uh right when that video came
out i lost my mother to like a two year
multi battle of cancer and i'm sorry i
realized there's no reason to do [ __ ]
you hate none so i wanted by the way 25
to 50 of this room hates what they're
doing right now that's that was me that
was honestly me and you really changed
my life so what i did was i got into i'm
like i'm a ninja with seo
i'm gonna go like give my services away
for free because there's no way for me
to kind of like go into a business be
like yeah like
i've done nothing but i'm to make you
money so i like reverse engineered that
because of what you said and i ended up
doing a lot of business for companies
and raising a lot of money and people
like how much do i owe you i'm like i
don't know like i'm just here to
make a brand but i've done a poor job of
like building my own brand and that's
mainly my question because now i'm ready
to start scaling because my goal is to
give back form a 501c3 form a
non-for-profit starter cancer charity on
behalf of my mom who grew up with
literally nothing and gave everything
she had so it really inspired me so
it's a lot like your content
but um now i'm ready to kind of in order
to do that since i'm working you did
build your brand you executed i did so
you're actually in a much better place
than a lot of people who've done a good
job amassing followers but actually
don't do [ __ ] like i don't have a lot of
followers but the companies i do have
they'll like they trust me like they'll
give their left kidney for me they're
like correct and so you should probably
take it and sell it on the black market
i'll take those
so i i think what you need to listen
what is old is always new i think
testimonials are powerful right i don't
think they should be boring like we saw
in the 90s but like i think that i think
you have built your brand like
like
every time big agency holding companies
try to razz on me
and play the card of like well it's all
gary and his relationships i'm like yes
ge and pepsi and chase and abi are so
enamored with me that they're seven and
six and eight year clients of us
they they're clients with us because
they've gotten results right because we
execute
you know yes maybe i've been more out
and about about how i've approached it
but you've built your brand you just
haven't now manifested right the equity
that you're sitting with and this is
what i would tell you
for everybody here that's looking for
new business this moment on linkedin
many of you
felt the good effects many of you
regretted for not jumping on board of
the golden era of facebook organic reach
on pages
right we can all agree on that
you know of it one way or the other you
either benefited from it or you kind of
wish you took advantage of it when i was
screaming about it and most people
weren't doing it
i'm going to give you another chance
right now
it's happening right now
it's called linkedin
linkedin is facebook 2011. right now you
could have no followers nobody on earth
knows you you make a video a picture a
written word a deck a something you post
it
and a lot more people than you think
will see it
you're welcome
thank you gary it means the world
linkedin testimonials
by the way
not everybody is remarkably handsome and
charismatic
not everybody needs to
find out how you communicate one of the
reasons i started making cartoons which
i think some of you have seen on
linkedin or instagram is because i keep
trying to find ways to show you that
there's a million ways to communicate
you don't have to have gift for gab one
take improv
ability to go you might write incredibly
well and your seven paragraphs on the
current state of long tail seo
post on insta on linkedin and get the
hell out and see three inbound leads is
real and it will go away because i'm
yelling loud
half will do it some will do it one will
do it
and then
it will get saturated the attention will
be matched by the amount of content
ads will go into the ecosystem you
understand
how many times do you have to see this
happen
like
right like how many times do you need
like how do you think i dominated social
i lived it with search
and with email
and then i'm like okay now i get it
i'm not making the same mistake when i
see it
you know people here are struggling to
get leads and win rfps and get new
business and literally the answer is
linkedin right now
and now i've said it and still
74 of you next week won't do it
which is how i got into insecurity and
parenting and perspective right because
i couldn't logically understand how this
is happening right now
and i know 74 of you are not going to do
it next week
i'm like oh
right
they're scared of judgment
oh right they don't want their uncle to
say they're stupid or when some
anonymous person says that they're ugly
that kills them
right they didn't get the luxury of
circumstance and parenting that i had
so now let me give it to them i just
want to be the collective shield
blame it on me
no no i'm serious bro
let's just do it right now once and for
all when what's that gary did it
just blame it on me when somebody leaves
a comment
and says you're stupid
tell him i told you to post it
tag me i will go in there and rip that
[ __ ] apart
thank you gary
hey gary seriously yeah hey how are you
um i'm just uh fantastic i'm i've just i
have to tell you i spoke a little bit
earlier right before you and i'm so glad
i didn't have to speak after
but um i
really enjoy what you're doing and i
have to say one of the things that's
challenged my question uh so i work with
experts um i help them become more of an
authority and i help them become like
influence in the space so a lot of what
we do is actually garyvee type stuff and
actually confession number two i
actually spoke at digital uh marketers
headquarters teaching a content strategy
that looks a little bit like yours that
you talk about that free deck i put out
has made a lot of people a lot of
[ __ ] money yeah yeah no joke you guys
um how the how to leverage video and
turn it into quote images and social
media posts and all that stuff and and
use square platform so you can put it on
instagram facebook linkedin everything
and just get the most leverage out of
your content my question to you is one
of those problems that i do have because
i the experts that i work with they're
running businesses mostly their ceos
founders or agency owners make sense um
the the problem that i have it's like
pulling teeth getting them to create
this content to invest in their own
personal brand i invented document don't
create
tell me more
they should film their day
okay
so i i totally get that people are busy
yeah they're busy and so or
they have to start a podcast which
becomes the top of the funnel for the
post-production creative across the
board
with neither
you can't
just so everybody knows unless you're
vlogging or you do a podcast or you
decide to become a guest on people's one
of my best arbs is being a guest on
people's
you think i want to talk to the paris
dude [ __ ] episode 100
but here's why it works i get to win
twice i know and it makes me feel good
that when he has me on his guests from
episode 101 on are going to be better
because he's going to leverage that i
was a guest that makes me feel nice
number two
when i do that interview i'm gonna be
filming it he's gonna ask me a question
that's gonna take me in a direction that
maybe i wouldn't have gone otherwise
that answer becomes a piece of content
that gets a million views on instagram
perfect
so the follow-up question is to any
client who is reluctant on creating that
content i'm going to send them this
video what would you tell them if they
tell me jeff i don't have time well then
you don't get the benefits of the
opportunity
there it is it's not super complicated
like that's great
don't have time to go to the gym
you're [ __ ] fat
have time you aren't
don't have time to you know
spend
a lot of hours with your children and
give them wisdom and love you might have
a more challenging relationship when
they're older
don't have time
don't get results
what i would tell them is they're making
decisions and valuing something that's
less valuable
than this
for the growth of their business
thank you you're welcome
what's happening gary life is good i'm
dre harris from arizona i've been a
pleasure yeah i've been dreaming about
asking you a question i've watched like
600 of your videos probably so yeah i'm
a fan but i would consider myself like a
recovering bro marketer if you will
right i was like a total [ __ ] for every
uh marketing tactic trick of the day
all that [ __ ] right yep and so uh
your content in large part has really
been the case about that real quick
because it can bring value i i always
love that story because what made you
that guy when deployed against something
more meaningful is going to create
results
i see it all the time
you know it's just a discipline change
absolutely so uh your content in large
part has been the catalyst for me and my
business partner really kind of changing
how we've been building the business for
the last 18 months and so how's it going
uh well it's going well we're giving
away a lot of free [ __ ] so talk to me in
a year or something i get it
uh and so you talk about right giving
away your best stuff for free yes i
think one of your recent quotes was uh
[ __ ] your seven-day trial um
uh and so
you let me explain
well let me explain i think it will help
i'm not against seven day trials i'm
against the fact that the seed of the
intent of that seven day trial was to
get somebody in give them nothing to
make them pay
that's it
so we we are unbelievably incapable
of not thinking about ourselves first
and so when somebody comes along that
thinks about it the other way
she or he can disrupt
that deck
that i put out that a lot of people
making money on
took money out of people who sell 1800
decks
that makes me happy
no doubt so if that deck is valuable
mazel tov but the reality is we've
gotten into a place in internet
marketing where that is not the case
98 of the time and that's something that
i think
you know should be disrupted no
different than taxi cabs or bookstores
if you do not bring value to the end
consumer you should be disrupted
go ahead yeah so you uh talked a lot
recently in some of your videos about
like whoever can hold their breath the
longest is going to win and so
uh
can you i guess kind of ex like
elaborate on that a little bit whoever
feeds their customer and their business
instead of extracting it so that they
can buy dumb [ __ ] to impress people they
don't even like tends to build better
wealth and businesses
done
thanks
i just don't understand that
there's so many people here running
smaller the reason so many people's
shops here are smaller than they think
is they're taking too much money out of
it
of course you can't scale you're not
hiring anybody because you're buying
stuff
there's not a person this room me
included that uses every room in the
homes they own
yeah i think about that [ __ ] a lot i'm
like [ __ ]
we don't use
any of these rooms
i wish i had the money back for
you know that's how i got to that whole
house thing that everybody got mad at me
for go ahead
i live in a studio i use all my space
let's go
minimalist man minimalist let's [ __ ]
go how you doing man i'm doing you
really put me in a good mood that was a
great [ __ ] start go ahead my dog
doesn't like it so much but i did it um
so i i quit my
[ __ ] love it
my dog might he comes to the office he
doesn't talk to you about it
true true i mean you might analyze the
barking in the eyes but
people are confused by me all the time
yeah say that seriously like like i
think about that quite a bit by the way
i'm gonna just build on that
back to like producing content
like there are so many people that tune
me out the first time they see me
because of the way i say something not
what i'm saying
they misinterpret the conviction or the
energy plus i'm very different here on
stage where cut you know i have the mic
than i am when i enter i mean i'm sure
mayor bill you've had to say that a
million times the way i interact at a
one-on-one level is so different
it's just the nature of the context a
bit
you know there's a part of me that just
watched too much randy the macho man
savage
and richard pryor that has now
manifested in a [ __ ] version of
those two in one
you know and so i think that i think
that
your dog might love it thanks man
i'll let them know i'll let them know
garyvee says that go ahead um yeah so i
quit my job like three years ago um to
like jump into entrepreneurship
full-time fell flat on my face like two
times um and then linkedin released
video right
and since then like i was one of the
first creators and my companies got i've
literally gone from like okay negative
900 in my bank account to my company is
about to pass seven figures so one i
wanted to say thank you two this is a
weird question you said this like
someone's gonna ask something [ __ ]
weird this is it can i have a hug i'll
try to get you earlier man hell yeah
let's
go awesome
i'm proud of you bro
let's go
[Applause]
hold on a second i don't think it turned
out go ahead
not yet
hi gary this is raphael from mexico i i
just saw that you launched your youtube
on spanish what opportunities was seeing
to start developing content in spanish
to u.s companies
uh well there's a lot of people that
you know speak and
understand spanish
yeah but
what makes you
take the next step
what what made me do that yeah
the the fact that i'm building enough of
a business that i can afford more
employees
so that i can get people on to the next
initiative
okay i want to remind everybody who uses
the excuse that gary has a team that i
did it all by myself for nine years
without one employee
and for all the og how many people here
were active on twitter in 2007
8 9 10 11 raise them
you all know who was putting out the
most replies and content
so
the re what what did i see i always
wanted to do it i just
systematically went to each initiative
that's my top priority and eventually
had enough scale on my team to get into
the transcription at scale that i needed
so you think it's a good opportunity to
start producing content you as a us
company to hispanic market
yes i do
i think anybody who's confused by the
growth of latin flavor in our like it's
funny when i hear people talk about
having a division and it's really fun to
have you maribel because we had a lot of
these conversations maribel has
incredible passion for her heritage and
her community like many do
i would always say to her i'm like we're
not building a division
this is this is america
so
i think it's a huge opportunity and when
you start digging and looking at the
metrics quant and qual i also think
spanglish is an incredible place where
some of the content is half spanish half
english like they're incredible
opportunities i'm so [ __ ] pissed i
grew up i was born in russia if i could
have been born in a spanish-speaking
country
i'd be [ __ ] dominating
[Applause]
hi how are you love your content by the
way another one for the people that
really are in my content you know how
much i love showing my uh report card
you know
i got real d's and f's in languages i
failed german one two times in a row on
this one great literally freshman and
sophomore year and in new jersey at the
time you had to pass two years of
language to graduate high school i
failed german one
horribly
both freshman and sophomore year on the
thesis that german was just like russian
and then like thank god big shout out
mrs kennedy my spanish teacher i
literally know three words in spanish
she called my mom like four days before
i graduated and said mr vaynerchuk i
know we've never spoken i just want you
to know that your son is gonna pass and
graduate high school but you need to
know he doesn't know a [ __ ] word
first of all i love you your content um
i started watching you originally when i
got into wine and kosher wine by wine
library with daniel rogoff a lot of
those wine reviews very good on behalf
of my community i'm orthodox everybody
wants to know when we're going to get a
kosher sign on empathy wines that's a
great great question the truth is i
don't know the answer to that but
i get inspired by stuff like this and
i will apps if you email me at gary at
vaynermedia i will put in a folder in my
epic thing and when i go and have those
meetings that's what i look at and i
will
ask the question of how we're thinking
about it and things of that nature
because nate and trout are really
driving a lot of that boat
but the answer is we're talking a lot
about empathy right now from
sparkling seltzer to cans to kosher to a
lot of different conversations so it's a
great time to ask the question okay
awesome another thing i noticed on
linkedin and with all your media you're
very into being yourself that's who i am
etc i know it's the past six months
maybe a little bit longer on linkedin
the curse words are beeped out how come
um
i i believe that i want to community
manage
um
when people are pushing back and the
linkedin community over a
long period of time
really was getting quite loud
at scale about the cursing and
the reality is i believe
equally in being yourself and always
never being
bigger than the audience itself so
the beeping out is because i genuinely
believed that it was becoming
detrimental to the message
and i didn't have the time like i did
back in the day to every time it was out
to go in and community manage and reply
to 44 people and apologize that that's
throwing them off but telling them why
it was important to me
so
i you know i feel like i'm still being
myself it's beeped you know what i'm
[ __ ] saying
you know um so that's where i'm at okay
awesome just for the last question i uh
so i have an ad agency and i manage
clients for like a couple thousand
dollars a month lots of times if a
client comes to me i'm managing their
social media they're paying me two three
thousand dollars a month like by the way
could uh you design this brochure for us
and by nature i'm just a giving person i
like to say yeah yeah no problem i'll do
that for you for free not charge
anything extra but on the other hand
i understand that people don't pay for
it they don't value it so where do you
draw the line
whatever your stomach is of the moment
there's no right answer to this question
the amount of times i've done things for
free that ended up being extremely right
is enormous and the amount of times i've
done things for free that ended up being
a path of being overly taken advantage
of that ultimately had negative
repercussions including burnt out staff
and many other things has been often as
well i
i tend to be like yeah
i tend to not you know people are like
gary you always talk about you know you
know giving and all this stuff but i'm
being taken advantage of i'm like you're
choosing to be taken advantage of
everybody's a big girl and boy in here
you're more than welcome to say no
and we're about to go through a big
transformation at vaynermedia we're
creating a very uncomfortable minimum
fee for yearly retainer or we're not
going to talk to you
that's just where we're at now that's
what i think is the right thing so
i think it's a personal question and i
think you should test both
i always tell people ask for a little
bit more money on the next scope
just as a testing mechanism because a
lot of you have subjectively decided on
your ceiling
or
one person said no and you're like [ __ ]
the market doesn't want it
no no one person doesn't want it
awesome thank you
hey gary how you doing man very well bro
my name is salvador um first of all i
want to say thank you man no just for
being here for everything that you share
i moved from cuba two years ago and i
learned english listening your podcast
man like
i learned how to say [ __ ] man
i get it
that's amazing
thank you so much for that honor how can
i help you so my question
we are using we are using an influencer
to promote our brand and
you know people
that interact with our ads and with our
post they just interact with the
influencer
we you know we split tests we do like
videos photos you know but people
continue to interact with the with
influencer what we could do to fire the
influencer
yeah
thank you so much man
let me let me you
you never want somebody else to have
leverage
more than you have the leverage if you
feel like it's gotten out of hand you
need to fire the influencer get a
different influencer i think a lot of
people should create influencers either
in themselves one big thing that i love
if you have any animation skills in
yourself or within your organization
way more people need to get into the
mickey mouse business
your influencer can be a cartoon and you
get to own the car the cartoon doesn't
get drunk the cartoon doesn't have
sexual harassment issues the cartoon
doesn't become a primadonna and want
more money the cartoon is something you
own
little v
that i put out and there's only one of
them that wasn't for kicks and giggles
i don't do anything for kissing hills
like animation is something to consider
or
understand it's 2019 and it's not about
production value putting your head on a
stick figure
literally drawing
a stick figure and putting your head on
it and then having post-production
animation skills and doing voice-overs
so that you could do tons of things
visually but you don't have to actually
be doing them there's another good free
idea
i'm loaded with ideas
this is about [ __ ] execution
thank you so much
[Applause]
so in 2009 i ran across this video where
a guy taught me the best wine to have
with froot loops
thank you um you know so i'm rosie and i
run redhead labs
we are an e-commerce development firm
mainly shopify and big commerce
um
my main question right now is we are
trying to convince brands
that tick tock is real yup and a good
placement
so how are you actually convincing the
brands that you're working with
that that's where money should be spent
by telling them and not spending a
second on it when they say no
the reason i went for the dramatic pause
is because i love you for asking this
question
because in the macro
it is the biggest vulnerability in the
room
the biggest vulnerability in this room
is trying to convince the unconvincible
i've done new business meetings that are
scheduled for an hour in 16 minutes
because as soon as i sensed it was over
i wanted the 45 minutes back
many thank you many
of you and our industry
will have an 18th meeting with that
person
i don't convince
i put [ __ ] on the record
and then some people benefit
and others
figure it out later
thank you you're welcome
hey gary uh first of all big fan thank
you for being here thank you um
so just for context uh my name is marcel
i run a company that helps digital
agencies run more profitably without
wasting time on spreadsheets so we're
about to launch b2b sas you know about
3k arr price point if you're in my shoes
what's the strategy that you're doubling
down on to start off with giving it away
for free to the most influential people
and then leveraging the fact that they
use it successfully okay
well i guess you're getting a free copy
of our software
maribel
uh and linkedin bro linkedin and maybe
you make i like when you ladder up a
show
maybe a podcast around efficiency
got it maybe a podcast called hidden
costs like if i was id i would say bro
start a podcast called hidden costs
the amount of money that people make
decisions in the funniest ways they make
decisions without realizing there's
hidden costs you know why i love culture
because rehiring somebody has a lot of
hidden costs
people are like i'm not going to give
you a raise you know for three thousand
dollars and then the person leaves
and they spend six thousand to replace
somebody that has no context
that's [ __ ] dumb
got it yeah so if you start a show
called hidden costs and you have
different people on from hr from
procurement to different stuff but the
underlining is the innuendo with even
the title is that your product cause
they're gonna know who you are you don't
even need to mention the company is that
your company is eliminating and creates
efficiencies and eliminates hitting
costs that's how i think about the world
level up your thesis from a programming
standpoint that brings even more value
because all of us will listen if it's 53
different topics of hidden costs but if
it's just sass it won't do you
understand
the show right now is called the agency
profit podcast so it's a little bit more
literal but [ __ ] no next speak is good
keep [ __ ] going thanks man now post
produce and [ __ ] quadruple down on
linkedin
thanks man you got it
hi gary how are you
doing good
i'm michael pavlov i'm coming from
creative house and new york marketing
association
so
my question is uh
imagine that you have nothing
except your mindset
and you are starting a marketing agency
today
what direction you gonna
go what strategy gonna apply
so one of the things that you have to do
when somebody pays you is you have to
provide value against that payment so if
you're starting from scratch you need to
sell
the thing that you think you're best at
no matter what it is
so
for me what i'm best at
is observing human behavior and
understanding new ways to get people to
know something
that's why social worked for me that's
why if i was starting today right now if
this was a bizarro world and today was
day one everything's the same for me i'm
just coming out of the business i would
probably call my company vayner voice
here's why i'm capable enough
to sell some consulting scopes about
where voice is going to keep me around
to eventually be the best dev shop on
alexa skills and google home because i
genuinely think that the voice device is
the only potential i do not think it's
guaranteed because i don't see the scale
yet but it is and this is what how i
look about tick tock i don't think tick
tock is yeah i saw i saw somebody
mention that i say instagram's dead and
it's not what i'm saying i'm saying tick
tock is the first platform that i see
that has the potential
to become the next thing
that's what i thought about social cam
that's what i thought about vine that's
what i thought about snap it's also what
i thought about instagram
and facebook because myspace was [ __ ]
killing it
so
i that's what i would do
but i have a pretty unique awesome skill
enough salesmanship and enough ability
to be right often enough in a short
enough period of time to benefit from
that
what i would recommend is people to do
what they're best at and by the way that
is what i did with vayner yes just so
everybody knows the first two years of
vaynermedia first two years of
vaynermedia all we did was community
management on twitter and facebook
that was our entire business nothing
else
because that's what i was best at
i wasn't best at creative on twitter in
2009
i wasn't
i was great at community management
great one more question i made a bed
with my friend that i'm going to shake
hands with you
but i want half the [ __ ] money
nice to meet you you're welcome nice to
meet you thank you brother
[Applause]
hi guys this is gaurav from india so you
know i've been
same here so i've been into the voice
first world for about a year and a half
i'm sorry one more time i'm into the
voice first world the wise first you
know building alexa skills you know the
google actions and you know for for one
and a half years
and largely you know what the challenge
is that the discovery is is a huge pain
in ass
and you know the google they don't share
any data
alexa doesn't share any data right so if
you're looking at
saying that somebody is going to build a
platform or product which we are looking
at we are building products now or going
to build works now you know in that
phase right now
in this space you know for a discovery
to solve the discovery problem they're
going to solve it
that's why the app store was built it
was impossible to find apps at first too
they'll build it
when they feel like it's time
discovery is a piece of cake
it's just at the mercy of the platform
yeah okay the end
so if so if somebody somebody's looking
at the voice somebody's looking at the
wife first platform from a discovery
point of view
it's gonna be
totally on the mercy of google and
amazon of the world pretty much
ish
okay now you're gonna understand why i
built a creative and media shop because
it solves that
our ability to create discovery because
of our ability to create content at
scale that's contextual for every
platform and arbitrage against the media
costs is greater than everybody else's
on earth thus gives me the opportunity
to have a leverage point against
anybody who's building alexa apps right
now because i can create the part that
they can't they become the commodity i
have the leverage got it so if somebody
is looking at building a product into
this real quick and i apologize i only
have the leverage until amazon flips the
switch and on amazon.com or on every
amazon package or on google's home page
there's discovery for every app
we lived this it was called apple apps
it wasn't hard the first year and a half
there was no discovery
got it and then there was so somebody's
looking at building a product into this
space
uh you know for for a discovery or a you
know in the voice space what would you
suggest that would be as a app for the
consumer yeah like you're not being an
agency and dev shop you're building up
your self or consumer yep
be great
at discovery
that's the punch line you know what i
mean you have to you have to add that
capability yeah otherwise you just built
a great app
tree in the forest
tree in the forest nobody knows you
built the best app
somebody's gonna build a better app in a
year because the capabilities are going
to be better and you're [ __ ] and
that's what happens all the time
yeah
all right thank you you got it
hey gary uh my name is abram gonzalez
i'm from new mexico i apologize am i
gonna be able to extend this a little
bit
cool go ahead
uh adrian gonzalez from new mexico uh
right now i'm the only person that's
client facing in my agency so i know the
next hire is going to be something like
an account manager my question for you i
do a lot on local networking that's how
i get all my clients
my question for you is how do you
gracefully transition
to like giving them an account manager
when they're really obsessed with you
by not selling them me
so how do you how how did you frame that
from the beginning with with your agency
because i imagine a lot of people come
to you thinking it's everybody with gary
yeah and then i'm like
not true yeah
here's maribel yeah
you can backbone me
if you pay enough
you know
by being unbelievably upfront
you know just uh
back to that gentleman the who talked
about me always saying yes
i'm telling you everybody's
biggest
vocab edition is no
bless you
and it was really funny and some of you
if you're very deep in my content you
may know what i'm about to say next
in russian superstition when somebody
sneezes right after a statement it means
it's true so i appreciate that sneeze
because it came after a very important
point that could have been glossed over
the biggest word that everybody in this
room needs to add is no
and it was hard at first because i had
no other leverage now it's easier
vayner's real but at first it was me
and this is pepsi and ge this is not
like you know and i'm like not me
and they're like what and i'm like yep
i'm like i'm the ceo i'm building
company i'm here
just by telling them the truth
thank you you're welcome
hey guys sorry to interrupt your uh
video i'm just giving you this call for
my number uh to let you know that you
have to join my text community
212-931-5731 hit me up with a text
hi gary my name is emark good to meet
you nice to meet you and i'm a mark not
sure if you remember us gary about six
weeks ago back in chicago we gave you
one of these boxes wanted to make sure
you had fresh breath thank you and then
about the last seven weeks we've sent
you one each week to each of the offices
there's a huge [ __ ] bag right outside
my office that's [ __ ] awesome
we win
so gary about 20 floors up from here
before i get there before i get there
could i have jason
goldie sammy and ada stand up for me
so gary we came out here this week and
instead of listening to all the sessions
we decided to say [ __ ] it let's go talk
to strangers and meet some new people
and we said let's start a podcast while
we're at it why not so these are our
first four guests will you be number
five
ah
yes yes
well played
super good
so good so [ __ ] good
[Applause]
thank you so much you're welcome
good hi gary my name is quinn goss
rochester new york um play i'm a two i
played in the nfl for two years i'm a
free agent right now on my own iron
visuals i saw your tweet
i'm watching that
you do watch i'm watching like it's so
funny right because one of the biggest
digs i get currently is interrupting
guests on the podcast which i'm
atrocious at
but but it's funny why that is it's and
i've started doing better in the last
week or two explaining why it is so that
people don't completely hate me but
the level of listening i do is far
greater than the talking i do
and um and that's very confusing because
you see me talking all the time
but i'm [ __ ] listening bro
guys question i have is
have you ever had a time where you had a
high ticket client come to you last
minute and this is more in the video
round and they wanted to get some work
done in my situation it was a travel
agency they wanted me to go to cartagena
colombia to go film for six days
the client didn't respect my prices they
weren't trying to like ball me they they
didn't we didn't end up working together
what do you what have you done in that
situation to try to get the client to
actually work with you and act
you know it's a mix of a lot of things
we've heard today like i just kind of
put my line in the sand and i'm
empathetic i try to explain to them why
i think the value is there but
make them you know very comfortably you
know understand if they want to go in a
different direction
all right thank you i mean
you know negotiating is a very
interesting game
you know it's people overthink it of
like who's going to blink first or
tactics like
people have you know just business like
people has a have a price for something
you know i'm always empathetic they may
have a p l issue they may value me way
more than i'm even asking but they can't
for some other reason
but
to to your credit you didn't think that
that was an exchange on the flip side
when your company is very early i think
you eat crow at scale because you need
unique case studies you need context
you know
um it just didn't work for you and
that's okay too there is no right answer
appreciate it kimbo says what's up by
the way
hey gary what's going on man i just want
to say thank you
uh it's been just awesome
uh hanging up out here by the way this
is unbelievable so like
i'm so sad right now and happy
literally i wanted to extend this
aggressively
on the queue here it says last question
need to call your daughter so i gotta go
but go quick okay i'm so sorry for
everybody just hit me up but i clearly
use that to make you feel sad
it works
so uh as a ceo
taking a business you know working with
clients uh that are bringing in like 50
to 100 mil what was the mindset shift
that you had
to work with the big boys like the
the fortune 500s nothing
nothing nothing
i let them come to me by being
historically correct with what their
customer was going to do
the reason i win
often
is because i'm not worried about the
person in the middle
got it yeah i didn't change for them
they changed for me
why
because i focused on you
the end customer is the leverage
not the relationship with the person
that writes the check
if you're playing long
perfect thanks it's your daughter i love
you guys
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much
thank you